so you I would bomb in front of a towel
I'd bomb in front of Patrice yeah yeah
and I'd be mortified so I would just go
and sit at the corner of the bar and
drink my Budweiser and just wait for the
next show just wait for the next beating
in between shows stand up New York would
like be packed out and they would have
to like empty everyone out and there's
no one in the room except me and Patrice
so I'm just like shut the [__] up don't
talk to him speak when spoken to with
Patrice right right because it's not
like I'm killing in front of him like
he's watching me bomb he knows I stink
he was young blood
who's your top five porn stars and I go
are we going by nastiness and he goes
[__] yes and I went Ava Devine and he
got okay like the first one I remember I
hit I hit him with that I was like David
Vine Lisa Ann and he went well okay he
was like he like liked where it was
going so I'm like oh I'm friends with
Patrice now and the next week I come
back and he's there and he walks in and
I'm like hey what's up Patrice and he's
like